>> ♪ ♪
>> HE HAD A LONG TIME FEAR OF
BEING POISONED.
ONE REASON HE LIKED TO EAT AT
McDONALD'S.
NOBODY KNEW HE WAS COMING AND
THE FOOD WAS PREMADE.
>> THAT'S THE ONE?
>> YOU THINK SO.
>> Tucker: HILLARY CLINTON WAS A
BIG STAR AT THE ONE PLACE HE
WOULD BE A BIG STAR THE
HYPER-POLITICIZED GRAMMYS
SHE HAS ONE THING IN COMMON WITH
HOLLYWOOD.
BOTH APPEAR TO HAVE A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PROBLEM.
PATTY DOYLE MANAGED CLINTON'S
2008 CAMPAIGN.
SHE SAID TODAY SHE WANTED THE
WOULD NOT HAVE IT.
>> I INTERVIEWED ALL OF THE
PARTIES INVOLVED.
I LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE.
I LOOKED AT EMAIL HE SENT AND
OTHER DOCUMENTS.
INVOLVED.
THE YOUNG WOMAN WAS VERY
CREDIBLE.
I WAS OVERRULED.
>> SHE OVER RULED YOU?
>> I WAS OVERRULED, YES.
>> Tucker: WOW!
HILLARY CLINTON PRAISED WOMEN IN
A VIDEO THAT WE WILL PLAY.
YOU CAN DECIDE FOR YOURSELF.
>> I WANTED TO SAY THANKS.
THANKS FOR YOUR FEMINISM AND
YOUR ACTATISM AND I HOPE YOU
[LAUGHING].
LET ME JUST SAY THIS IS DIRECTED
TO THE ACTIVIST BITCHES.
>> Tucker: MARK STEIN IS ON
TONIGHT.
HE JOINS US.
HI, MARK.
>> HI, TUCKER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT VIDEO?
>> THAT LAST ONE IS PATHETIC.
IT'S LIKE WATCHING SOME WEIRD
KIND OF GOLDEN GIRLS ON MEET
"MEET THE PRESS" WHERE YOU HAVE
OLD BROADS OR BETTY WHITE DOING
A RAPPING GRANNY ROUTINE.
IT'S PATHETHIC THE OLD BROADS
HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN EXPOSED
YET AGAIN NOT AS A CHAMPION OF
THAT BUGGED ME.
SHE HAS A SALTY MOUTH.
WHAT BOTHERED ME SHE DESCRIBES
HERSELF AS AANIST.
WHO HARASSED WOMEN, I WOULD CAN
TURN THE BLIND EYE TO ONE
PREDATOR FOR 40 YEARS IT'S EASY
TO TURN A BLIND EYE TO ALL OF
THEM.
IT'S A CLASS AND POWER THING.
THAT'S THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN.
THE WOMEN THAT BILL CLINTON HIT
ON WHETHER THEY WERE INTERNS OR
LOW-GRADE STAFFERS, SHE REGARDED
THEM AS TRASH.
SHE AND GUYS LIKE HARVEY
DEMOCRATS.
A WOMAN WAS ON TV AND BELIEVE
ALL WOMEN AND ZERO TOLERANCE.
WAIT A MINUTE, WHAT ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON?
SHE IS STILL WORRIED THAT THE
CLINTONS ARE POWERFUL ENOUGH TO
TAKE THE TIRE IRON TO HER IN THE
BACK ALLEY.
IT WOULD BE IN THE INTEREST OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY FOR THEM TO
TELL HILLARY CLINTON, STOP DOING
YOUR CATSKILLS SHTICK ON TV
EVERY 10 MINUTES AND GO TO THE
>> Tucker: TOOK 48 YEARS TO HEAR
THAT PHRASE.
IT WAS WORTH THE WAIT.
>> TUCKER, POLITICIANS SHOULD
NOT DO COMEDY.
IF THEY DO, THEY SHOULD DO IT
SHOW.
SHE SHOULD SAY I WON'T DO IT
AGAIN THE YEAR 2057.
SHE WOULD BE DOING ALL US A